tout de suite julien chez edag autre
envoyé spécial qui se trouve lui à
zaporizhya et une alerte vient d'être
lancé asa porridge a
alors bonjour judith il ya eu une alerte
tout à l'heure en milieu de matinée
effectivement qui a les sirènes ont
retenti dans la ville de happo ridja
nous nous trouvions à ce moment là dans
notre hôtel nous étions sur le point de
partir en tournage lorsque le personnel
de l'hôtel nous a tous membres
simplement dit de nous ruer dans un abri
souterrain qui se trouvait à quelque à
quelques mètres de l'hôtel il y avait
des civils avec nous évidemment et on a
vu dans l'abri souterrain on a vu la
peur dans le regard des gens il y avait
beaucoup de familles leurs priorités
pour les parents qui avaient des enfants
c'était évidemment de protéger les
enfants on voyait des enfants spin scène
assez assez assez étrange puisque d'un
côté nous avions les enfants qui jouent
et comme s'il ne se passait absolument
rien et de l'autre côté des parents qui
étaient totalement effrayé à l'idée
d'avoir des bombes qui acquit qui
atterrissent à l'idée d'avoir des
déflagrations dans la ville où tout
autour de la ville finalement l' alerte
att a été rapidement levée il ne s'est
rien passé mais c'est une séquence
extrêmement intéressante puisque pour
l'instant aux apories jha a été épargné
par les bombardements mais d'y aller il
y a eu dans l'oblast donc cette année
c'est à dire dans la région de zap
orridge à plusieurs bombardements qui
ont été recensés de cette nuit à 160 km
de là dans la ville de mélie topol les
russes auront attaqué la ville et ont
pris la ville on a appris ça ce matin
donc c'est à 160 kilomètres et donc
maintenant les habitants se demandent si
leur tour va arriver bientôt
voilà merci beaucoup julien cheddar
merci à vous